uh collaborative research institute in
theoretical computer science and uh as
well as our semester programs we run
these summer clusters welcome to the
uh workshop for the interpretable
machine learning cluster
uh interpretable machine learning in the
natural and social sciences and let me
start with a big thank you to the
organizers of this of this workshop uh
shai ben david zach lipton ruth turner
and binhu
thanks to those folks
it will be a
really exciting week
i'm going to hand over to i guess bin to
introduce the workshop in a moment
just a few
things about logistics
the food is outside
please don't bring food and drinks into
the auditorium
for lunches the food i guess i should
say for breaks lunches you're on your
own so
follow a local
there are plenty of options
masks inside are strongly recommended
you know outside
they're optional of course
at lunchtime if you need to leave bags
there are lockers on the far side of the
building on this level with a pin code
so you can you can use those
and you know we're doing things in a
in a hybrid format on zooms
omed is our videographer so he'll be
helping speakers connect computers and
and microphones and so on
um
and the other thing to to do is thank uh
kelani penland at the back here uh our
events coordinator for all of the local
arrangements a big thank you to
all right ben
[Music]
thank you peter for the intro to science
institute so i'm being you from here
berkeley statistics and ecs has been
really fun to work with zach lipton my
co-chair i also get help from shai to do
this workshop this is the beginning of
the classroom interpretation learning
and the design
thoughts was really try to ground this
cluster in
the subject fields from physical science
biological sciences and also in
philosophy causality and also law
interpretation learning or intimate
abilities really sits in as a bridge
between ai machine learning
and also humans right so on one hand you
have integral
authentic interpretation from physical
science models we can really help
advance sciences
on the other side we also need to build
trust into ai and interpretation also at
the center
recently i think eu just had a new law
going to put in place 2023 called data
service act and there it's about all
service organizations and they
explicitly now ask the parameters
when something content is recommended to
a user needs to be meaningful so we can
see that more things will come and the
hope will ground ourselves at the end of
the workshop we have better
understanding of the different views and
also um
have some synthesized principles and
things we can work on during the whole
month
i'll give the mic to my coach here
zach will also share the first session
hey thanks ben
and thanks everyone for uh taking a you
know radical step of uh showing up in
person um
um
you know um i guess it's like a general
um
framing
uh i mean this is maybe my perspective i
don't want to speak for anyone else's
opinions but
um
you know there's uh
i just like in the context of a class
went back and reread uh leo breiman sort
of two worlds paper and you know there's
i think like a a reasonable perspective
that
there's a world of like
a universe of
like a set of practices of modeling the
world
um
that is sort of theory driven and uh you
have a set of commitments about what
you're modeling and what everything
means and
roughly what sort of relations you know
exists between them and you design a
model and uh it's sort of clear what the
interpretation is um of course
philosophers will still debate what we
mean by an interpretation but there's
something
comparatively clear about
what the interpretation is of the model
that that's sort of given force by the
set of beliefs instead of the theory
that sort of drove the model and in some
sense like a lot of the modern practices
of machine learning
emerged um from sort of to some degree
being willing to forsake that for the
sake of you know achieving some
objectives predictive objectives things
like this
um and now we find ourselves in a world
where we have good predictive models and
often sort of want to have our cake and
eat it and i think um we're in a strange
space where now we're we're not sort of
in a practice of even thinking about
what is an interpretation what what is
even what is even the object that we're
interpreting are we modeling the natural
world are we trying to say something
about the model it sort of slips around
even within a paper
and um
you know i think we're in a weird stage
where a sort of you know like the status
quo and it's not what any
let's say what any one individual is
doing or what everyone's doing but very
often for people to sort of say uh
um i did some stuff i added a layer i
generated a picture this is this is my
interpretation and we just make a sort
of broad kind of sort of wild claim and
um to some extent uh i guess one of the
hopes of this workshop is to
just sort of ground ourselves again and
uh to sort of
you know think like what the hell are we
even talking about what are the actual
problems we're trying to solve and
instead of doing that by sort of looking
inwards and i think there's a bit of a
tendency we have in ml to
invite the same people to speak at you
know every single event and we see the
talk and we know the talk and we know
the slides and we recognize them
um to really spend the workshop looking
outwards and so bringing people from
philosophy from economics from the
life sciences from natural science from
physics from
economics um from various like social
scientific contexts and
from a lot of places where
people closer maybe to the action of
something of what are we hoping to
achieve um by an interpretation or or at
least bring an outside perspective
um
so i'm i'm really excited uh you know i
think uh we were really fortunate to
have a bunch of speakers who have sort
of uh braved the perils of uh the
apocalypse to come join us here and uh
yeah looking forward to the workshop
um our first speaker today is uh david
banks um
i guess i know david reasonably well so
um i can give me this like a slightly
more personal introduction you can look
up all of his achievements
um
i think you asked maybe um a lot of
philosophers about the cmu now a
professor at ucsc was i knew him as a
head of philosophy at cnu when i joined
and yesterday some philosophers about
the cnu philosophy department some of
some some some of it's great some say
it's weird they say how is it weird and
they do all kinds of weird things like
they hang out with computer scientists
and they show up at machine learning
conferences and they're not so
doctrinaire about where papers are
published and so you know in some ways
i've been
a beneficiary of the weirdness of uh
people like you know david who uh are
willing to come and cross these bridges
and and be the glue between discipline
so
um dave's got a
uh kind of
large uber of work but has among other
things uh worked a lot um related to
philosophical aspects of cognitive
science neuroscience um causality and
causal discovery and also some of the
moral and political questions um related
to artificial intelligence so
um it's a great honor to have him here
and thanks for joining us
nobody claps on zoom that's so it's like
oh wait
why are people clapping uh thanks zach
and bin and uh chai for the invitation
to come
uh up the coast it is um
this is the second in-person thing i've
attended in three years i think so or
two and a half uh so it's a little bit
strange so bear with me
um
so
i wanted to
talk about um
a topic having to do with sort of
interpretability in neuroscience but i
want to just right off the bat say the
in neuroscience part kept getting
smaller as i was working on on setting
up the talk um so i'm gonna
i am gonna do some stuff on neuroscience
but that's not actually gonna be the
main focus of what i'm gonna be talking
about for most of the 30 minutes that i
have here or my exact am i supposed to
leave q a
sorry
i should have remembered this i
apologize
30 minutes include the q a okay great i
will make sure to leave time for some q
a
but there is a whole panel okay great
okay
we'll see we've got
a very nice schedule i will say to have
actually time to talk
you're going to break right up
sounds good
all right um so
you know as
as as both zach and ben were saying
there's an enormous amount of work
that's been going into interpretability
explainability intelligibility
understandability all of these bitties
um that people look for
in
the kinds of models and systems that we
build using ml techniques okay um and i
think
what's striking is that the vast
majority of it has focused on
um interpretable models and i'm sure
that we're going to be hearing a lot
about interpretable models over the
course of the next few days um
in particular people
will in various ways restrict or bias
their search spaces to only be a subset
of the possible models so the kind of
classic oh i'm going to only consider
linear models or additive models or
uh you know additive with smooth
transitions or whatever it may be
and so you know maybe
people will it'll only be a bias you
allow for a more complex model or one
that seems to not make very much sense
um if that's the only way to get good
predictive power right so it isn't
necessarily a hard restriction in terms
of the search space but
that's one standard way of trying to
generate interpretable models to try and
understand
the pieces that fit together um and how
they fit together in a sensible way
whatever that exactly is supposed to
mean
the other i think main way that people
have focused on
trying to do interpretable models is
building what i've called here
sorry for the
somewhat vaguely philosophical jargony
stuff but these are
you give me a horribly complicated model
that i can't make any sense of and i
look for sort of local approximations
things that are as if this is how the
model works right so the classic one
here would be something like lime um
where you just are looking for the sort
of local
roughly linear model that's right at
around whatever the decision point is
so you're getting this sort of
a facade
of
what's really going on right and you
might say well that's you know that
can't possibly count as interpretability
let me just sort of put my cards on the
table and say sure it can't
um i can use newtonian mechanics to
understand how things move through space
even though that's not technically how
physics works right we use
approximations all the time in our
attempts to understand the world around
us and you know so personally i have no
problem calling those interpretable uh
though i can imagine there are some
people who might object to it
but i want to focus on something
different
which is the vast majority of this work
starts with the assumption that we
actually have variables that mean
something that are the right kinds of
things to be looking at in the first
place
and i want to push back on that and say
well a lot of times and i'll give some
examples on the next slide
a lot of times actually we don't have
variables that make sense what we're
measuring we don't think are plausibly
the things that our models ought to be
built out of
and i think they're you know this is
roughly the thing when people want to
understand not
how a deep net works
say in a local post-hoc way but rather
when they say well what are the
intermediate layers all about
right the hope is that there might be
something in there that is interpretable
which is to say a set of variables at
those intermediate layers that make
sense
um and so that is related to some of the
things i'm going to talk about but i'm
not going to talk about deep nets
and i want to point out that this is
actually
at least in the worlds that i operate in
a pretty common thing that what we
measure are not the variables we think
we ought to be messing around with or
the ones that make sense in terms of our
theories um so
uh one example of this is if we think
about climate science um so there's a
lot of that that happens down at uc san
diego with scripps uh and climate
science climate scientists don't operate
at the level of a random buoy floating
in the ocean in the north pacific
those are not the variables out of which
they're building their models they're
building things out of say el nino
southern oscillation or the pacific
decadal oscillation or all of these uh
ocean indices that capture the behavior
of large uh parts of uh the ocean either
the uh sea surface temperature or the
pressure radiance around it um
but of course that's not what we measure
we don't measure el nino that's what you
see you see these nice plots of a
univariate thing that changes over time
we don't measure a menu that's actually
an aggregate of over 100 measurements
okay
um
educational psychology
uh so
many of us in this room or online uh
teach
and we want to know things like
when do my students actually learn
something and they surely don't learn
anything from any particular
sentence i utter that is not the
transformative thing that suddenly leads
them to have a full deep understanding
or that leads them to get an a in the
class right the performance on one
particular question
in an exam is not the reason that a
student gets a net it's not even very
predictive of what what grade the
student will get unless you have
incredibly high stakes exams
and yet that's what we measure
i can generate you know canvas is great
for this i can generate this huge
spreadsheet of how students did on every
single little question
but that's not the thing that measures
understanding
um or the thing that i was going to sort
of talk about the most today when i'm
talking about an example which is
neuroimaging
so this is um that's a shot of dti
defensor diffusion tensor imaging this
is a standard fmri
right every couple of seconds we're
getting a snapshot of the blood flow
within the brain
um
and
in neural imaging you know these the
colors here are all added after the fact
nobody thinks that this random voxel
that's measured by fmri is actually the
thing that we should build our theories
about
you know now people in neuroscience and
neuroimaging often talk about we should
build our theories based on
regions of interest
what on earth is a region of interest
it's supposed to be a part of the brain
that
operates relatively coherently
but what that means we don't really have
any idea
so what what all of these and i could
have given a lot more examples
of sciences in which
what we measure is not what we think our
theories should be built from so we have
to do some work we have to if we want to
have interpretable variables we're going
to have to construct or discover them
depending on how active you think the
role of the human is in all of this
so what does this look like well there's
actually a lot of different methods that
people use um
i bin them into these sort of four large
scale groups that's the way i tend to
think about it so the first is that you
basically cluster
so i've got a bunch of variables and i
look for
high positive intercorrelations between
those variables especially over time
more generally across units right so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
well
say in the brain case if i've got fmri
measurements i'm going to say well
where are the parts of the brain that
light up which is to say with an
appropriate time delay show increased
blood flow
um which parts of the brain light up
together
let's call those a region because
they're they're all doing the same thing
right and obviously when i say it that
way it's obvious that this is a bad
inference
um but nonetheless it's a pretty
standard practice the same sort of thing
happens
sometimes in clay cases like climate
science where we look at which parts of
the sea surface for example
tend to change roughly together
a different strategy
is to do clustering at the level of the
dynamics
so
we see a lot of this for example in eeg
measurements where you're looking at
electrical signals on the surface
on the surface of the scalp
and what we're doing there is often
we're looking for sort of what i call
here shared motifs right so dynamic
signals that show up similarly perhaps
with a time delay to account for
transmission distances between the brain
and the surface of the skull
right but it's still a clustering it's
just now we're doing clustering based on
some higher order feature
um a third is that we look for things
that have a high correlation with the
target
some target you pick the target so el
ninos actually was originally defined as
the
sea surface temperature readings that
were highly correlated with the strength
of the monsoon season in india
if you look back in the
late 19th or early 20th century that's
where that ocean index gets defined
if you look at a lot of work in the
early work in neuroscience trying to
understand for example what happens in
primary visual cortex it was principally
saying well
which things are highly correlated with
some target namely the in this case say
the occurrence of some visual stimulus
out in the environment
okay so this is essentially a kind of
variable construction based on a
supervised thing we've got some target
and we want to say what happens to be
correlated with it well that must be a
detector or indicator or something
having to do with that version
and um then
the fourth group is finding things that
work in a model and i'm guessing we're
going to hear at least some of this
perhaps this afternoon in the session on
causality
but
i think causal feature learning is kind
of the the epitome of this uh the idea
that i'm going to construct variables
where the criterion that i'm going to
use is essentially their suitability to
uh to provide a stable over time or
across individuals
causal model
so we've got these four different
methods four different kinds of classes
of methods um
you know there are going to be ones that
don't exactly fit or are hybrids but uh
early on a tuesday i'm not going to
bother with trying to get to those
details right this is a high-level way
of thinking about
now what i really want to emphasize
about these four different classes of
methods though
is that you can actually understand all
of these at each of these as simply
different loss functions
and that's that's really all of these
can be represented as optimization but
over very different kinds of loss
functions
and loss functions are fundamentally and
here i'm i mean this
not in the mathematical sense but in the
philosophical sense are about values
they're about what matters
so uh putting on zach mentioned i do a
lot with ethics and policy of ai putting
on that hat i would just make the
observation that anytime somebody says i
just do machine learning i don't do
ethics my response is sure you do
why did you pick this loss function
rather than that
every time you pick a loss function you
are doing ethics
you may not have known your anathesis
congratulations um but you're doing
ethics because you're saying this is
what matters
this is the kind of performance that's
relevant this is the thing that is
important in the world and that's all
values are
we will talk in ethics about values what
they mean is values are what matters
and so when you pick a loss function
when you pick a criterion
by which you're going to construct your
variables you are bringing to bear your
values now which values are going to
depend on what your goals are
what are you trying to achieve with the
particular
thing that you're constructing okay so
which one of these kinds of methods we
use
is going to depend on why i'm doing this
variable construction in the first place
okay there is no privileged one that is
always the right way to do it it's going
to depend on what i'm trying to do
now okay
sure if i'm doing science i have to pay
attention to why i care about this
question and then that shapes the method
i use this probably seems really banal
so here's um the
here's the kind of kick
i just i'm going to assert this as a
claim i'm not going to give you the
theorems because again
9 45 on a tuesday i know i'm going to
i'm in simon's institute but i didn't
want to give people theorems
and proofs
but
i'm just going to assert that claim
which is that which of those methods you
use can lead to different best variables
even in the large sample limit
we're not talking here about oh well in
finite data sure one will be better one
will be the other
and the sense of different here is a
very strong sense of difference they are
in a deep sense
essentially incommensurable unless you
go all the way down to the measured
variables themselves now of course the
different constructions are defined on
the same measured variables
but that's like saying you know
you can understand
everything as just you know
quantum particles or whatever quantum
wave functions or whatever i don't do
philosophy of physics so i don't know
what it's supposed to be right that's
not interesting right we do think
there's a difference between a human and
a computer
and even though we're all just you know
quantum wave functions at the bottom
so
there is a reason to carve off you know
human as distinct from
and
so the way to think about this is that
if you're doing different methods
sometimes actually you would say that
the relevant variable is human plus
computer
actually it would be sometimes it'd be
my left arm and the screen
that's the sense of sort of strong
incommensability that
these are not it's not like there's a
subset and it's like oh the causal ones
and then there's everything else or
something like this
they are not translatable into each
other without loss of information unless
you go all the way back down to the
measured variables
what that means
is that this technical result when
combined with the previous slide means
that
which variables we construct are going
to depend on our goals
and so therefore
our interpretable machine learning
depends on our goals like what variables
we use
which variables are the best ones for us
to use to try to understand the world is
going to depend on what we're trying to
do with that
so it's not just that you know the
models are going to depend on our goals
because we want to do a predictive model
versus a causal model
this is what variables we even use
within those models will depend on what
we're trying to achieve
and in this sort of strong way that it
isn't that there's a super fun you know
beyond the super fine grained of the
measured
there's no way to inter-translate
between
it's not like we've got a hierarchy of
models or hierarchy of variables here
um
so what does that mean for example in
neuroscience well um
the reality is that you know if you do
neuroimaging most neuro most of the raw
measurements that you get are not
interpretable in the usual senses of you
can make sense of them uh they're about
other kinds of things whether patches uh
volumes of brain activity
or
sort of strange aggregations and
interactions of
different brain regions manifesting as
uh surface measurements
and so we do have to construct
variables um and unsurprisingly within
neuroscience there have been a lot of
methods that do this so there's
clustering methods that are about high
local intercorrelation
there are ones that are about high
predictive power so mvpa multivariate
predictive
analysis um
so vpa basically says what are the parts
of the brain that are really good for
predicting something
um there's now a number of people who
are working on constructing variables to
get causal dynamics
uh whether static causal dynamics or
that is to say sort of snapshot
iid samples or the causal dynamics over
time
and
notably
different variable sets are constructed
depending on which of these methods we
use
these kinds of incommensurable variable
sets are constructed depending on what
we use
so if i'm trying to build a causal model
of the brain i will parsilate
essentially the brain differently than
if i'm trying to predict
behavior
and not in a subsettable kind of way
again it's not a hierarchical thing it's
this part of the brain gets lumped in
with this object for my theory if it's a
causal model and it gets lumped in with
a completely different one
if i'm trying to build a predictive mode
so
what this means is it means that we have
a sort of
there's a there's a lurking risk right
so you might be thinking yeah okay goals
matter and science so what the lurking
risk is about a sort of
problematic
what in philosophy of science you would
call pluralism about science
which is i'm trying to build my causal
model zack's trying to build his
predictive model and we each build
models that are interpretable within
those goals
and those models are incommensurable
they cannot be put together and unified
into a single model unless we go all the
way down to sort of the level of a
neuron
and we don't know how to think about the
brain as a collection of individual
neurons
that is unlikely to be an interpretable
understandable model if we're having to
go down to that level okay so that's the
risk here is actually a very practical
one which is a kind of frac potential
fracturing
of science
based on what the goals are not about i
mean of course there's a fracturing the
neuroscientists don't always talk to the
the economist
but we're saying within a science within
a you know people who study the
hippocampus
you can get this kind of fracture
so it's something that we need to
acknowledge
and i don't have great answers about
what to do um this is i apologize a bit
of a negative talk in the sense of
here's this issue that we need to at
least acknowledge
and
what are needed are
either better methods or ways that we
have systems that we can easily tune
what criteria we look at or balance
criteria
and ways of representing the choices
that are made in the construction of
variables as a kind of metadata at the
very least
so i mean i think there are
um broader implications
that we get as i'm saying this kind of
incommensurable interpretability
depending on what it is that i'm trying
to do um my model is not translatable
into somebody else's model of the same
thing
um and so we need to think not just you
know there's been this big push
in the xai and interpretable ai
community to think about well
interpretable for whom like you know
that the explainable sorry i'll use that
term explainable model if i'm doing loan
approvals might be different if i'm the
loan officer versus the explanation that
i as a loan applicant would want
that i think
there's getting a lot of traction and
people are talking about that that's the
for whom
and i think really it's about the why
um in fact i i would i'll make the
contentious claim and then just move on
blithely um that it's actually not about
for whom at all when we say for whom
what we really mean is why that it's all
about the goals and the functions it's
not about who we're getting it's just
that particular
people are stereotypically in particular
roles with
corresponding goals
um and in particular
what i want to emphasize if we think
about sort of more broadly
scientifically societally
this is where we keep finding in our
work this is where the most of the
theorems have been showing
we get these pretty we can get pretty
big uh differences in terms of the
variables that are constructed based on
whether we're doing predictive models or
causal models
um
and that suggests that we might have to
have real
we have a sort of potential concern
which is how do we get
how do we figure out which one is more
societally important in some sense in a
context
so if i'm building a neuroscientific
model
say
for treatment versus diagnosis
right
diagnosis versus treatment
it's going to matter which kind of model
i use um and so there's a lot of
i think concerns about things like
say some of the stuff that's happening
at nih to try and find grand unified
theories of the brain especially with
regards to mental health and mental
illness
um
all right so um with that
um you know i think that
this is maybe not the launch talk that
that second ben and and chai wanted but
um
you know i think it's important right
from the very beginning to not just
focus on the models but to think about
the variables that go into those models
the things that are the sort of uh
building blocks out of which we build
our theories and understandings of the
world
and which of those variables that we
have
um to be interpretable
intrinsically depends on what our goals
are this isn't a well we can find the
best fitting set of find the sort of the
right variables we can to use the
philosophical terms carve nature at its
joints right that's this classic
philosophical idea that
maybe what we can do is we can sort of
there's a natural way to carve up the
world that works for causation and
prediction and
uh supervised clustering and and all
these things um and what we've
shown unfortunately is that's wrong uh
in fact there's not a single privileged
way to carve nature at its joints
and so we've got this sort of
fundamental tension based on what we're
trying to achieve
and we're actually seeing this this part
i didn't go into in detail um i just
sort of asserted there are these
different methods that that show up but
in fact you know we've got examples of
different papers where people are
looking at ostensibly the same data and
getting very different models in part
because they're getting very different
variables based on what their goals are
so we actually are seeing this in modern
neuroimaging practice
um and
and we're trying to figure out what to
do about it so with that i will just say
thanks and thanks to the collaborators
and the conversationalists some of whom
think i'm really really wrong so please
blame me for these not not these folks
so thanks
all right thanks dude um
great okay so i will just run around
with a microphone is that
very interesting and
i i really enjoyed it uh
somehow it looks to me very related to
the question of what is a good method
for clustering
because what you call variables is some
way of of clustering the measurements or
the measuring the
raw variables
and uh
i just want to mention that i
it's almost a
copy i mean of a talk that i have about
clustering that says there are different
goals and with different goals you're
going to use different clustering
methods
and
you cannot have a universal clustering
that is better than any other and i
wonder about what you think about this
difference between
telling this story in the context of
clustering and telling this story in the
context of interpretability
yeah i mean i think so yes i agree and
um
uh
the the the you can tell this about just
clustering one thing that i think is
important is that
so when i first started thinking that
way i was thinking about the clustering
and the response i got from multiple
people including some on this slide
right now is well yeah but if you just
if you look at in particular causal
models those are going to be the right
variables
and so the problem with clustering is
well you have you have small finite
samples if you just had infinite samples
and
you thought in terms of causation then
this all goes away
and so that's what led to the the
theoretical work of finding yeah no it
doesn't help at all um the problem
actually just keeps getting worse so i
agree within those four classes
there are certain kinds of
incommensurability results even within
each of those four groups
um we were thinking about the even
bigger thing of you know is there maybe
you know again this philosophical dream
of carving nature at its joints
and no uh
you know even in the large sample limit
it's it's just an
intrinsic problem to our uh limited
epistemic capabilities and the same
thing because in clustering even in the
infinite limit of samples right
yeah
so great talk um so i was wondering like
um amongst the challenges you have
listed
do any of them also subsume
um
the requirement that the user can
sometimes specify
what kind of variables they are looking
for
and i have seen this um
fairly frequently in industrial settings
where
people say that i want to understand
your predictions in terms of
a certain kind of persona or division of
personas um some clustering of variables
of demographics right so
i think that leaves room for
people to be able to specify um in some
language what
are
sort of the
um meta patterns they're looking for so
if i were to translate to what you said
it's it's not just different losses but
losses with
maybe different structural constraints
around what you can discover
yeah so at least some of those are are
actually going to be
the kinds of structural constraints that
separate distinguish these different
kinds of things um so what what are the
mod what is the model class i mean
all of these in some sense what you do
is you you're looking at to use the
language of clustering you're looking at
a plus which way of clustering or
parsolating the things that i've got
will lead to a good model now it might
be a sort of simplistic almost identity
kind of model it might be a complicated
causal model but they all fit into that
and so you can certainly restrict
in various ways and
it is the case that i want to emphasize
the the can here is an important term
it's deliberately not always because it
might be that in some cases if you
restrict things in the right way there
actually is a single best
cluster single business set of variables
for all of the different goals okay
this is not an impossibility theorem in
the sense that necessarily
there's going to be a conflict um
now
empirically we seem to see it a lot but
but it isn't that so um an interesting
question
i think
is um whether the kinds of things you're
talking about
within a particular domain right because
in neuroscience you're not going to want
to you're not going to care about
demographic variables in the same way
you might on a social scientific data
set
is it the case that under the kind of
natural restrictions that people impose
in a domain
that actually these theorems fail
right um because that would be an
interesting thing it might be that
within a domain
that there's a kind of well no these are
the things we care about and that
simplifies it in such a way that we do
always get
a single best set of variables um i
don't know anyone who's got any results
on that i think it's an interesting
question that we should be asking
oh hi
uh you stressed the loss function um and
and that are driving things um uh
can you elaborate on how um uh do you
pick the loss function uh based on like
the results that you anticipate or based
on what's uh what what's what what's
what's known or is it more so more so
like like a discovery thing like you
start you start with a loss function
that um
in your in your experience you you've
started with loss loss function that
seems to be sense uh sensible and then
and then makes statements about it and
um that's that's that's the first part
and the second part is like like i'm
like a multi-objective loss function um
have people considered that i know this
is pretty loaded but across like
different neuroscience modalities and
as far as making interpretations um yeah
yeah so um
i mean in general what people do is they
use the loss function that people use in
their lab or that you find in the random
papers i mean so unfortunately a lot of
times the loss function is not chosen
intentionally or with real thought about
what the right one is
um the right way to do it i would argue
is figure out what you're going to try
and do what kinds of variables you care
about and use that to then figure out
what the values are and so therefore
what loss function um
so a kind of intentionality about the
choice is a good thing
it does not always happen in practice
now to your second question about um
about
multi
potentially multi-term loss functions um
so i actually have a
a kind of contrary view to a lot of
people which is i think for variable
construction that's usually not a smart
thing to do
because what you get is you get
variables that you don't know how to
interpret because they're kind of the
predictive ones and kind of the causal
ones but they're not really either one
and
and so it's actually hard semantically
to make sense of the things that result
from that
so for variable construction i tend to
be
uh i mean you can do it
obviously you know any of these take any
two loss functions you can always
just do a weighted average of the two um
so you can i just i tend in my
experience in neuro imaging and in the
social
[Music]
areas of social science
uh particularly public health kinds of
things
i don't find this actually being that
useful to do
multi-objective loss functions for the
variables for the models yes
um but that's because they're what we're
trying to capture is the actual
trade-offs that societally are important
for example about you know false
positive false negative rates and those
kinds of things
so how about we'll take one more and
then we'll enjoy our extended coffee
break and uh
you encourage everyone to corner dave in
i think at least on the official
schedule they absorbed the coffee break
in
after the
and then had zina and then panel but i'm
happy to go either way
we had a speaker cancel so we have an
extra half hour to annoy david and cena
there is a break in the current draw
right the question is just whether to do
the break between the talks but not
between cena's talk in the panel or do
it talk talk break panel right we could
not on our break you know
gradual anyway
um
sometime between now and 10 minutes from
now we'll decide but okay in the
meanwhile we have a uh what joe promises
me will be a longest
well longer comments or something so
first let me say that that in our
notion of causal model that i've been
pushing
um the choice of variables is very much
up to the modeler so i'm i'm totally
comfortable with with that picture and
and it's a hard choice
um one thing that might be relevant here
is is i i i did some work with uh my
former process senator becker's and an
update with sander and frederick
everhart where we were talking about the
notion of abstraction so what does it
mean that a
a high-level model captures a low-level
model where i think of the lower level
model is the pixels or or the details
the ocean current the high-level model
is the language you really want to talk
about
and you know so we had
definitions that sort of talked about
causality works the same way whatever
you do at the high level there's a
corresponding thing at the low level i
won't go into details the definition
so you can make sense out of the fact
that that
all the models that you're looking at
are compatible with the low-level model
as far as causality goes they're just
talking about different things
and and again i'm totally comfortable
with that but but at least in principle
it seemed to me that
that there's like a lattice of models
where you can you know you have two
models here but they're in convention
because they talk about totally
different things but you can imagine a
model that sort of speaks lies above
both in some sense
um and maybe it's closer to the you know
the really low level maybe below both i
don't know um that that that you know
whose variables are the union of the
variables in some sense and
um and that got to be able to make sense
out of that
is there any intrinsic reason you can't
yeah so um
so
uh
first i would say
i really like the the abstraction work
with sander and frederick and um and
it's it's cited in the draft paper that
sits behind us so let's try to get a
piece like that no no no but i think
that that's exactly right um and
yes there
so
it is
you can think about it as as a lattice
right
um
you know give me two higher level models
i can do intersection i can do union
write the variables right and either way
i'm moving around in it that's all very
well defined
and
in our at least practical experience
when you go
to the intersector join right um first
of all you're you are taking a hit in
terms of the performance relative to
whatever the loss function is that led
to these being picked as the optimum
right
the variables also become less
interpretable
just in practice when we look at what
the variables are you can start looking
at well yeah but that it's really kind
of these two half variables and you just
kind of want to put them together the
problem is you want to put them together
in different ways
depending on what's trying to do so i
would have thought so computation let me
just quickly say so
this is just a
an empirical claim which is yeah
computationally it's all perfectly well
defined cognitively
there seems to be a real cost right so i
i suspect you're right but in some sense
i would so in other words you're looking
at the world your way with your
variables i'm looking at the world my
way with my variables now we're trying
to construct the model that sort of
speak combines the variables well then
we have to start talking to each other
and sort of sort of speak explaining
your you know you're a weird way of
looking at the world from my perspective
i in terms of things that i can
understand the vice versa so i can
imagine
quite easily that that would be
cognitively difficult because
i don't get your way of looking at the
world right and then vice versa right so
so there's work involved right so that
but but that might actually if we're
talking about humans and uh that might
actually be useful work
in in terms of you know it's forcing me
to understand
how your perceptions of the world
map to mind right that's that's exactly
what's
the mathematics
of of what's going on is exactly that
yeah yeah how do we find that intersect
uh model in the lattice so that we can
actually map between it's not
necessarily you know understanding that
and and forcing people to is not
necessarily a bad thing um yeah i will
say it stands in contrast to
what i think a lot of people assume
which is that it's a kind of classic
reductionist picture which is yeah yeah
so everyone gets subsumed into it i
agree it's not that yeah
and then that's the part that i really
am most concerned about in a lot of ways
[Music]
great thanks everyone okay so maybe um
how how's this planned why don't we take
something on the order like 15 now
and that'll preserve like five minutes
of our
surplus break time for like a potty
break uh after the second talking before
the panel or something like that
good all right yellow let's go